(upbeat techno music)
- So today, we are trying
Hot Cheeto infused tequila,
which we saw on Tipsy Bartender.
- I'm into Hot Cheetos, I'm into alcohol.
Am I into Hot Cheetos and alcohol?
- I love Hot Cheetos.
I don't like tequila shots.
(they laugh)
- We both like the food
and not the alcohol.
- Maybe they'll like,
cancel each other out.
- You said that there
would be Hot Cheetos,
and you know this girl loves Hot Cheetos,
and then I saw the tequila.
Is this a prank?
- I feel like this is gonna be
just like a spicy
margarita, but in a shot.
- But tequila?
- Yeah, that's what a spicy
margarita's made from, tequila.
- Show's my alcohol knowledge.
Cool, all right, let's get this started.
- So, we are taking this mason jar,
and we are filling it
half-way with Hot Cheetos.
- I didn't wash my hands.
- Let's shake it.
(driving rock music)
- This would be a great Halloween drink.
- Oh my God.
- You know what?
- That is fucking disgusting.
- I just don't want diarrhea.
That's all I--
(heavenly music)
Okay, we got Tums.
- I came prepared, actually.
(upbeat techno music)
- Cheers, let's do it.
- Woo.
- [Woman In Pink] Oh.
- Oh no.
Tastes exactly what it looks like.
- (coughs) No.
Mm-mmm.
- Oh.
- Okay?
- Yeah.
- (laughs) "Oh."
- Oh my God.
That was disgusting.
- I don't agree.
I thought it was good.
- It was gross.
No.
That, you know what,
whoa.
Gimme a minute.
- I like the aftertaste of spice though,
'cause I really like spicy
foods and spicy drinks,
so I feel like, that nice
warm feeling in my throat.
But the actual shot
taking was pretty gross.
- This would be like, if
you were stuck on Everest,
and you were freezing,
take a Hot Cheeto shot.
Warm you right up.
Girl, it was one shot.
- Argh!
- I liked it, Maya didn't.
Whatevs.
- It was like drinking something
that told your soul, "Hey, you suck."
- We had a different experience.
- What am I saying?
(He laughs)
I don't know.
Hello?
- I kinda liked it.
- It wasn't bad.
- Yeah.
- It was definitely
better than tequila alone.
- For sure.
Sorry tequila makers.
I know that's like, you're
rolling in your grave.
- It kinda is like spicy,
so it kinda burns after.
- If I was in a pinch, and
I wanted to make a cocktail
for someone, and all I had was
tequila and Hot Cheetos, I'd make it.
- I don't have any mixer, but
I have Hot Cheetos, y'all.
That's what you, that what we did.
That's exactly how, what they did.
(upbeat techno music)